Heat.
[Music]
[Applause]
Heat. Heat. Heat.
[Music]
[Applause]
Hello and welcome to this episode of
What's Up Prof. I'm Martin. Hello,
Walton.
Yeah, let's let's not ask how we are
today. No, we can dive right into it. We
just dive right into it. Bypass the the
whatever they call it these days. Yeah.
I don't know if it's even formality, the
formalities, the introductions, the what
have you. Yeah, I can skip all of that.
I can open with prayer, then we can get
right into We can't skip that. No. Okay.
Our heavenly father, thank you very much
for this opportunity. We ask that you
please be with us through this this
discussion and enlighten our minds and
uh bless us in Jesus name. Amen.
Amen. We've been talking a lot about
final events. Yeah. And we've been
saying a few things as
to what the aim and the object is, where
the world is
heading, implementation of the mark of
the beast. And we keep saying these
things and people
are confused because others say, "No,
that's not what it is." is you know the
mark is something else and this is not
that way and this and that and the other
and I thought you know let's go back to
the word of God the word of God is
absolutely
amazing and it unfolds the historic
events progressively
so as you go through the Bible there's a
prophecy which sets a framework work.
Yeah. The next one colors it in. Mhm.
The next one adds more details and so
revelation is
progressive and the problem with
humanity is they get fixed in
ideas and they run with those ideas but
those ideas are not what the Bible is
really portraying. For example, uh,
Israel, the Jews were absolutely
convinced that the first coming of
Christ would be like the second coming
of Christ.
Okay? And not even the disciples could
get that idea out of their heads after
being with Christ for three and a half
years. They were fixed in their ways.
And when it didn't
happen, they were stunned. They were
destroyed. Destroyed. the foundation
crumbled away and they ran like rabbits
from a from a serpent. Yeah. And uh they
couldn't figure out what was going on.
This is because people have fixed ideas.
So we have to go back to the
scriptures. Now the scriptures uh tell
you exactly what is going to happen, how
it's going to unfold. You read the book
of Daniel recommended by Jesus. You read
the book of Revelation and you get the
picture. But if you don't have the
blueprint and stick to the
blueprint, you can go into many side
alleys and end up in dead ends.
Unfortunately, that's what happens to
most and that's why there's so many
denominations. Yes. Because everybody
has taken one of those ally alleys and
that's where they go. Yes. Let me give
you another
example. Uh the church over the
ages, whether it was the Israelites or
whether it was the Catholics or whether
it was the Protestants,
they all believed the church is going to
rule here on earth. Yep.
They didn't realize that the kingdom of
God had been pressing in since the time
of Christ. Yeah. And that you were
called out of the world to enter into
that kingdom by faith. Okay. So what you
mean is that the kingdom of God was
pressing in towards here. Yes. That's
what the Bible says. The Bible says the
kingdom of God was pressing in. In other
words, it was it was intruding in your
life's decisions.
It was the kingdom and you had to join
the
kingdom. But the church believed, no,
they are the kingdom. They're going to
rule as proxies on behalf of Christ.
And all of humanity is going to be
subject to them. That's what the Jews
believed. But that most like you said
that through the ages, that's what all
believed. They couldn't get rid of the
idea. and the idea of a millennium, the
temporal rule. Now, everybody wanted
Jesus somehow in the picture, but the
church has to rule. They still want it.
They still want it. So, it's so
confusing because then they have the
idea of futurism
where the church will be
raptured. So, it won't be here. So,
obviously, if it's not here, it's not
going to rule, right? No. So, who's
going to rule then? Well, then the Jews
will rule down
here and that'll be the case. But the
others say, "No, no, no. That can't be
right. Uh, the church must rule." So,
you have the millennials that say, "No,
the church is going to rule. Where's
Christ?" Well, he's somewhere there.
Yeah, we'll acknowledge him, but you
know, just leave us alone. We're ruling
on his behalf. On his behalf. We're the
proxies. Just stay back there. stay in
your little corner and leave it to us.
We've got this thing under control.
It's full of stories about how that
went. So, this is this is the problem
with humanity, their fixed notion of how
it's going to
work. Now, I was reading this book,
Martin. I had it on my shelf and I'd
read it before and as you can see it's
very well read and it's falling apart
and it's very
old and
it's
moldy. I love these
books. And this is the approaching end
of the age by Gratan Guinness. Okay. the
approaching end of the age. What's going
to happen here at the end of the age? My
book is literally falling apart, but
that doesn't matter. I can still read
it. Now, what's interesting to me is
this was of course the Church of England
theologian who also wrote Romanism and
the Reformation. These are excellent
studies. Yeah.
And I was reading in this book about the
approaching end of the age and the idea
of what is going to happen now. Is
Christ going to rule? Is the church
going to rule? And they've got this
notion of the millennium where the
church is going to be in control. That
was Catholicism's idea. That was
Protestantism's idea. That is the
dominionists in the United States of
America's idea at the moment.
Yeah. Wasn't it Satan's idea as well?
Yes. It's there to confuse, right? He
didn't he also want to be the ruler? He
wants to be the ruler. He wants to be
the the proxy who rules. In any case,
the idea of this temporal millennium
where the church rules was so fixed that
this theologian, he read a lot of books
and articles by theologians on this
issue and he studied and he studied and
he studied and the more he studied the
more confused he got. So eventually it
says here in the introductory pages of
this book and you can see they are well
marked here. Somebody else marked this
before me. I don't know why they marked
it like this. They marked it so that you
can hardly read it anymore.
In any case, he decided he's going to
put all these theologians
aside and he's going to study the Bible,
the Bible and the Bible alone.
And he came to the remarkable conclusion
that the Bible clearly teaches a
pre-millennial coming of Christ when the
kings of the world will be
eliminated
and Christ will rule. But nowhere can he
find that he's going to rule down here.
Yeah. So he thinks to himself, but you
know, he must somehow rule down here. So
maybe we're just missing it somewhere in
the Bible, you know. But one thing's for
sure, he's coming before the millennium.
And it says here in this book, and he
could never be swayed from that thinking
because he'd studied it in the Bible and
it was absolutely clear. But this
millennium, where is the evidence in the
scriptures? Well, it must be there, but
I can't find
it. You see how it works? That's how
entrenched ideas are. It's tradition and
ideas that you don't study out for
yourself. That you don't study out for
yourself. In any case, this man was
absolutely clear on what Daniel taught
about the antichrist for
example. And uh he has a few interesting
points on that. And he says the Bible is
so is so accurate. It's so clear on this
issue and then it it puts it beyond
doubt. It says it is this woman. It is
this church and on her forehead is
written Babylon the mother of the
harlots
and the abominations of the earth. M and
then he did a study on this word
abomination which we totally
independently just did the other day
when we spoke about the abomination that
causes desolation. And we came to the
conclusion that whenever the Bible
speaks about abomination, it's idolatry.
And we didn't get it from any other
source but the Bible. We got it from the
Bible and the Bible alone. And I'm
reading there and I see he says exactly
the same thing. So if she is the mother
of abominations, then one of her main
features must be
idolatry. And he says, well, how can you
deny it? They walk around with the host
that they claim is God, and this wafer
bread has to be
venerated. So where's God? He's in that
bread. He says, "Not even the pagans
ever developed an idea where you would
uh make God and then eat him." He said,
"Not not even the pagans that I that was
when we were on the road." Yes. It's
like cannibalism. It's like cannibalism.
So the whole doctrine of
transsubstantiation that has to be
developed around this, he says that's
idolatry. and not even to speak about
Mary and saints and having them as
intercessors and mediators and advocates
when the Bible is so clear that these
are idols that have been put in the
place of Jesus Christ and then walking
around with the statues which the Bible
clearly forbids and bowing down to them
and all of these rituals and things
we'll talk about it in a moment in a
little bit. He says, "How can the how
can anybody not see it?"
But the amazing thing
is humanity seems to
be numbed.
Mhm. and they forget about these things
and they forget about the clear picture
that Protestantism had about the
idolatry and that Rome was considered as
the antichrist and they were all in
harmony with that idea. So how does it
really work? What really happens at the
end of time? How does this
restoration work? Where is it leading
to? And how can we reconcile it with
current events? That's the
question. Now, the Bible is not just a
literal prophetic book. It also is a
book of typologies. And in the
typologies, you have certain truths. And
those are outlined. And in the way that
they unfold, they become lesson
books for our time. Yeah. So, we're
going to talk about the final
reformation. And I'm going to take one
book in the Bible, which today is two
books in the Bible.
So, that's the book of Ezra and the book
of
Nehemiah. Now, originally that was one
book. There was no division. Ezra and
Nehemiah. Yeah, it was one book and it
was probably written by Ezra. Ezra maybe
some final adjustments by someone else,
but Ezra was the scribe that wrote it.
Now, why have we got two books? Because
Jerome, when he put together the Vulgate
for the Catholic Church, he divided it
into
two. Now, that's not a serious problem
if you divide it into two. As long as
you don't take out as long as you don't
take out anything. But originally it is
one. So we will consider it as one.
We'll deal with both of them
together. And this is the story of the
post
exile. And if we follow the line of
logic and the symbolism and the
typology, then we should be able to
figure out what the events of the last
days will be all about.
The Bible is amazing in that sense. Yes.
And people don't actually they rarely
want to study it like that. Correct.
Like you mentioned earlier, you can use
the books of the Bible to see what's
going parallel happening in our time.
Correct. And now we're going to show us
how. So the the history backdrop is
Jerusalem is in
ruins. The temple is destroyed.
The buildings
are destroyed. The wall around Jerusalem
is broken down. Was this now when they
were taken off to Babylon? And then they
were off in Babylon and they stayed
there. According to the prophet
Jeremiah, they were going to be there
for 70 years whether they liked it or
not. And after the 70 years they would
be able to return. Now this happened in
stages
right and there were three rulers that
made it possible. The first one was
Cyrus
and he issued a decree that the temple
was allowed to be rebuilt. Was that
after the 70 years or was it before the
You see Babylon had taken them captive,
right? So we'd moved past the stage of
Babylon now already. Meo Persia was
ruling and the first ruler of Meo Persia
who was going to set the captives free
was Cyrus. Okay. It didn't really take
off. They started rebuilding the temple
but the work was somehow halted and then
it had to have a new impetus.
The next ruler that was to look at the
history and find out that the Mes and
the Persians had made a decree and once
they had made a decree it couldn't be
altered, right? Yeah. That their laws
their law stood. It's like God's law. It
stands. And that ruler was
Das. And he made a decree that uh the
temple was allowed to be restored.
That was the
temple. Then the what about the rest?
Now we're moving to the time of Ezra and
to the time of
Nehemiah. And this is the restoration of
the wall and the the nation as a
independent nation subject of course to
the ruling powers but at least again a
sovereign nation.
So how was this implemented? And this is
a type of the plan of
salvation and of the kingdom of God.
Yes. All right. Okay. So we need to look
at the various aspects. So let's call it
the final re
reformation restoring what had been
destroyed because of the apostasy of the
Israelites. Okay. And what was their
main apostasy?
They were following the nations around
them. Mhm. They had introduced idolatry.
Which is an
abomination, right? And they had
neglected the law of God. And one of
them in particular stands out, the
Sabbath. Yes. So, let's have a look
what Providence has written down for us.
So, we're talking about Ezra and
Nehemiah and particularly the post
exelic
restoration. But before we get there,
let's just go to Corinthians. 1
Corinthians
2:5 says that your faith should not
stand in the wisdom of men but in the
power of
God. Remember men have certain ideals.
Yep. And they have certain
expectations. And normally it involves
power resting with them. It's always
selfish. It's always selfish. So our
wisdom should not be in the wisdom of
men. Chapter 3 11 says, "For other
foundation can no man lay that is laid,
which is Jesus Christ." Your your faith
must be Christ centered. He's the
cornerstone. Everything has to be on
him. Verse 12 says, "Now if any man
build upon this foundation, gold,
silver, precious stone, wood, hay,
stubble, every man's work shall be made
manifest, for the day shall declare it,
because it shall be revealed by fire,
and the fire shall try every man's man's
work of what sort it is. And if any man
work
abide, he has built thereupon, he shall
receive a reward." Okay. So what can you
build on the foundation which is Christ?
Well, you can build
gold. That stands for character.
You can develop the character. Silver.
Silver is purified in a furnace of
affliction. So you can develop a a good
character through patiently enduring
affliction.
precious stones. They reflect the light
of the
lightgiver. But you can also build with
wood, hay, and stubble.
When the fire comes, they're gone.
Right. Yeah. So, some of the builders
are using the things which they should.
They should develop characters in
accordance with Christ. They should be
able to uh live in the furnace of
affliction and use it for a positive
purpose so that they can reflect the
brightness of Christ's glory. Or they
can build with wood, hay, and stubble
and it will burn away. So this actually
shows
you what type of attitude you use or you
have when you start building your
character. Correct. And um I think John
the Baptist summed it up very well.
He must increase. I must decrease.
Whereas humanity is, I must increase. He
must take a back seat, please, because
I'm in charge here. Yeah. Even worse,
they say, "Please bless me while I'm
taking the front seat." Correct. All
right. So, this will be tested and those
that have built
correctly, they will be rewarded. Now,
the reward is eternal life obviously,
right? And then Paul makes it very clear
that the church, the members in the
church are the temple.
Living stones within the temple. Now
some of them might be wood, hay, and
stubble. So you will have them in the
church. We must talk about it's it's
interesting because that's very
important. This is amazing how the Bible
just fits in together with everything.
Beautiful. Beautiful.
So, let's jump right into Ezra and break
it down as we go through the chapters.
We'll just highlight a verse here and
there. We won't go through everything.
That'll take
forever. So, now in the first year of
Cyrus, king of Persia, that the word of
the Lord by the mouth of Jeremiah might
be fulfilled. The Lord stirred up the
spirit of Cyrus, king of Persia. Then he
made a proclamation throughout all his
kingdom and put it also in writing. So
this is the decree of Cyrus the great.
Thus Cyrus, king of Persia, the Lord God
of heaven, has given me all the kingdoms
of the earth and he has charged me to
build him a house at Jerusalem which is
in Judah. So this is the temple. It's a
decree. Go and restore the temple. After
the words of Jeremiah, 70 years of exile
were coming to an end. you can now
rebuild the temple. You're not going to
be an independent nation yet, but uh you
can rebuild the temple. Now, in those
days, uh
everybody worship different deities and
people believed that deities were
regional. Uhhuh. So in Jerusalem, the
deity that had to be worshiped was the
one that the Jews worshiped. It was
still an idolatrous idea.
But that's why they allowed it. All
right. Not because they were necessarily
convinced that this was, you know, the
only
deity. But that was the regional deity.
So he had to be rebuilt. But any case,
he made a decree the temple may be
rebuilt. Now, what does the temple stand
for? The temple stands for God's people
that are to proclaim the gospel.
And what is the gospel? The gospel is
the good news of salvation. Mhm. So the
temple
service was an enactment of the plan of
salvation. Yes. It was in ruins. Yeah.
Typologically, what does that mean,
Martin? That go there was no go a gospel
being preached anymore. No, they had
changed it into a into a gospel of
rituals and self-importance.
Christ was out of the picture.
So the temple was in ruins. There was no
plan of salvation to present to
humanity. Gone. Go and restore it. Yeah.
All right. They become an idolatrous
nation. Go and restore it. So that's
point number one. I just want to ask um
when he now said you mentioned that they
had to go back because their god was
ruling there and or you know that so but
just I want to know it says there that
by the one god of heaven he he's giving
this decree. Yes. Now interesting that
some of these rulers actually
acknowledged that the god of the
Israelites was the true god like
Nebuchadnezzar. Nebuchadnezzar. But did
his people acknowledge that? No. They
had this idea of okay, we tolerate it
because it's the regional deity.
Now the ruler had to first come to his
senses before he accepted the truth like
Nebuchadnezzar and then it's him and not
necessarily is the rest of the people.
Correct? Because when he was first
confronted with the idea that God
determines what happens on this earth,
he said, "No way. I'm going to make this
statue gold from top to bottom. Right.
Yeah. So, I'm going to oppose this deity
because I'm I'm the bee's knees. And he
still didn't have it quite right
afterwards because then he made a
another statue, a decree that says
everybody should worship um the god of
Daniel and his friends. Correct.
Confused. But then he went through a
time when he had to eat grass. Yeah. He
went on a on a whole food plant-based
diet.
You can put it that way. And and the
interesting thing is he came to his
senses. Perhaps that's not a bad idea.
Well, there's a second guy. Even the the
um young man that went away from his
father and when he was with the pigs, he
also ate pulse.
Puls came to his senses. He came to his
senses. So, let's let's not throw in too
many commercials before we put people
off here.
So the interesting thing is what
happened as a consequence of this
decree. So then rose up the chief of the
fathers of Judah and Benjamin and the
priests and the Levites with all them
whose spirit God had raised to go up to
build the house of the Lord with which
is in
Jerusalem. Typologically, let's restore
the gospel
because it had become an idolatrous
place. The gospel was gone. It was
selfserving. Verse seven says, "Also,
Cyrus the king brought forth the vessels
of the house of the Lord, which
Nebuchadnezzar had brought forth out of
Jerusalem and had put them in the house
of his
gods." So those vessels had been
carefully preserved by
God even in pagan temples. Interesting,
right? Well, I I think they got a bit of
a fright with Balsasa's banquet and when
they were misusing those artifacts. Now,
the interesting thing is that those
vessels and the ornaments and the
furnishings, they stood for something.
Yeah, they had typological value. So,
they had to be put in right settings
again. So we have to look at how this
restoration was to take place. And the
first thing they did, Martin, we read in
Ezra 3:2, is the first thing that they
restored was the following. Then stood
up Yeshua, the son of Jezedc, and his
brethren, the priests, and Zerubbabel,
the son of
Shiel, and his brethren, and buildeth
the altar of God of Israel, of the God
of Israel, to offer burnt offerings
thereon, and is written in the law of
Moses, the man of God. First thing to be
restored was the altar. Yes. What does
the altar stand for? for the crucifixion
of Christ stands for the cross of
Christ. So the altar was in ruins. They
had become interested in sacrifices and
issues without realizing what they
meant.
Restore the altar. Now let's go
historically and ask ourselves, is there
a
time when this type that happened to
literal Israel can be applied to
spiritual Israel, the church? And the
answer is
yes. Was there a time when the church
was so
idolatrous that the altar had been
destroyed? The plan of salvation was
gone. Christ was set aside just like the
Israelites had set aside the cornerstone
for sure and didn't know what to do with
it. And this had to be restored. Well,
Martin Luther wrote the work he's one of
his famous works, the Babylonian
captivity of the church.
Now if we read what it says about that,
it says Martin Luther argued that the
Roman Catholic Church like the ancient
Babylon had held the church
captive primarily through its
sacramental system.
He challenged the idea of seven
sacraments, arguing that only baptism
and the Lord's Supper or Eucharist were
truly biblical sacraments.
Luther critiqued the church's misuse of
the sacraments to control and coersse
individuals, arguing that the gospel's
promise and faith should be the
foundation of Christian life according
to the Lutheran
Reformation. Now, in my opinion, it
didn't go far enough. I agree because a
sacrament in Catholic thinking is a
means to salvation. It's a worksbased
thing. So if you attend the mass, you'll
say that's salvational. If you attend
the
confessional, that's
salvational. Any one of the sacraments,
as they said, the ritual was
salvational. That's idolatry.
So in my opinion, there's no such thing
as a sacrament. I agree. There's no
salvation in the sacment. Nothing.
And Martin Luther took a while to get
rid of the idea of
transsubstantiation and that uh you know
this was an idolatrous practice. It was
a symbol and it was representing what
Christ did and not a ritual that we do.
So in the end there should be no
sacraments. Everything is
Christ. But he found that Babylon had
kept Israel captive and so Rome which is
termed Babylon in the Bible, the mother
of harlots, had kept the church captive.
Yeah. And the altar was destroyed. So
the first thing to be restored is the
altar. That's where Protestantism came
in. They distanced themselves from the
idolatry. They threw out the statues and
the altar of offering brought back
Christ as the means of salvation. The
spiritual altar, the spiritual
altar. So the final reformation post
exile Jews exile in Babylon,
Christianity's exile in Roman
Catholicism. That was the typology as
the reformers saw it. So the final
reformation starts with putting Christ
back into the picture. Yeah. Does that
make sense? Into the center. Correct.
But it doesn't stop there. No. Because
we have to continue in this book. So now
they're rebuilding the
temple. Now the temple stands for the
whole plan of salvation. Remember you
had the outer court, the righteousness
of Christ covering you as you come
through the door which is Christ. You
had the altar. Christ is the sacrificial
lamb. That must be restored. He will
wash you. Then you go into the holy.
Then you go into the most holy. The
whole plan of salvation is laid out
there and this has to be restored. All
of it. Yeah. Because the whole thing in
its completeness is a reference to
Christ. everything single thing correct
so let's go through this
postexile
restoration in other words
post middleage Roman Catholic pagan rule
Ezra 3:8 Now in the second year of their
coming into the house of God at
Jerusalem in the second month began
Zerubbabel the son of
Shiel and Joshua the son of Jazedc and
the remnant of their brethren, the
priests, and the Levites, and all they
that were come out of the captivity unto
Jerusalem, and appointed the Levites
from 20 years old and upward to set
forward the work of the house of the
Lord. So basically, you're setting up a
church structure.
That's very important. All right. So,
typologically, they put the priests in
place because the the type had not met
anti-ype yet. the offering was still to
take place. But if we apply this to the
church, that means setting in order what
the church has to do, the ministers, the
work that they have to do, the
proclamation of the gospel, the plan of
salvation has to be restored. It's
putting it back into organ organization.
And what did they do? Well, they sang
together by course in praising and
giving thanks unto the Lord. Did the
Protestant Reformation create the great
hymns of the Reformation? Yeah, very
much so. Uh Martin Luther wrote hymns.
All right. Now, what did Catholicism
done? Everything had become a chant.
Everything had become mystical.
And it was the mysticism and the
ambiance which captivated people not the
message. So it was the feeling the
feelings. So here comes the Protestant
Reformation and you have this boom in
the world in the musical
sphere and the hymns start becoming
meaningful. You're actually singing
doctrine,
right? A mighty fortress is our God.
Now, irrespective of how it all started,
it was no longer a chant. Yes. That was
now
actually heavenly. Heavenly. Can you see
the typology over here? So that's what
they started doing. And what did they
sing? Well, they sang psalms. That's a
hym book. And so you had to create an
entire new hymn book for Christianity
and move away from the chants and the a
maras. How many time was the avi maria
sung in in Trump's inauguration and
presidency now the whole time this every
time there's a big event or something
you'll hear that what is what has that
got to do with the gospel right nothing?
No I think it's just making a point.
Okay. And then why did they do it?
Because God is good, for his mercy
endures forever towards Israel. And all
the people shouted with a great shout
when they praised the Lord because the
foundation of the house of the Lord was
laid. The foundation, no other
foundation can you lay but Jesus Christ.
Can you see the restoration? That's a
post exile.
But many of the priests and Levites and
chief of the fathers who were ancient
men that had seen the first house when
the foundation of this house was laid
before their eyes wept with a loud voice
and many shouted aloud for joy. So there
was joy and
tears. Do you think there was joy and
tears in the Protestant Reformation? For
sure. It's a relief, right? Maybe they
didn't have the Vatican anymore with its
pump and Michelangelo and this and that
and the other
and they had simple churches and they
said, you know, the pump is gone. The
pump is gone. But many of them but they
found the the cornerstone, the true
jewel, the true foundation had been laid
again. So this is the typological story
where we're applying what happened in
the type to the
antitype. Now when you start doing
that you get problems of course. So
there will be adversaries that will
oppose the rebuilding. Right?
Ezra 4 verse one. And when the
adversaries of Judah and Benjamin heard
that the children of the captivity
buildeth the temple unto the Lord of God
of
Israel, well, they were very, very
angry.
So, here's a quote out of Romanism and
the Reformation by the same
author that wrote this
book, and he says, "Wherever you have a
priest instead of a
preacher, an altar instead of a
communion
table, wax candles instead of the
sunshine of divine
truth, ceremonial instead of sound
doctrine,
sacraments instead of saving
grace. Intoned liturgies instead of
earnest heartfelt prayers. Splendid
music instead of spiritual worship.
Gorgeous vestments. Can you imagine the
conclave at the moment? The pomp and the
glamour and the vestments.
Instead of gospel truth, tradition and
the church, aren't we going through a
stage of tradition and the world is in
awe, Martin? Yes. They are right back at
the portion where uh the the reformation
has to start again. Yes. No. All of this
is gone. Did you get my point? Yeah.
Well, where you have this tradition and
the church instead of it is written and
crossings instead of Christ. There you
have Romanism. No matter what it may be
called, beware of
it. However attractive the architecture
and the incense, the music and the
ceremonial, solemn ceremonial, beware of
it. You can even make this modern in a
modern setting in a modern church not
only in the cath catholic church because
that's why he says no matter what it may
be called other churches when the music
is oh taking you away now I would like
to I would like to encourage the
listeners through your mind's eye just
let the
television pictures that are coming out
just run through your head of all that
pomp and ceremony all the cardinals with
their dawn hats walking in ceremony, the
staffs and the big this that and the
other and the chanting music and
everybody is in
awe. Isn't it a sad state of affairs?
Martin, where's the emphasis now on that
and on the coming pope that will be
inaugurated? Do are we preparing the way
the same for Jesus to come? Uh no, no,
no, no, no. So after lamenting the fact
that Protestants, this is no gratonus,
that Protestants are so willing to
ignore all the prophecies regarding the
antichrist. Prophecies on which all the
reformers were united and even embracing
spurious counterfeits such as futurism
etc. So after lamenting the fact that
Protestants are so willing, etc. That's
what I'm writing because I don't want to
sum up. I don't want to put a huge quote
in there. We'll go back to his quote
now. And he asked the question in his
time. Now, Martin, this was
in
1887 when he wrote
this. Is this the position you adopt? Is
this the conclusion you defend? Are
these the views you ad advocate? You a
Protestant?
And this after all that has been written
upon the subject and all the blaze of
light which history and experience have
poured upon it. If it is, look to it
that you do not be found fighting
against the truth, waring against the
word of God, resisting the testimony of
the prophetic spirit, hindering the work
of the reformation, promoting the
progress of the apostasy, opposing
Christ and helping
Antichrist. Has he got a point?
I And the way he puts it, it's
beautiful. Isn't that what the world is
doing today?
100%. He
continues, "Even the Romanists
themselves shame you in their
clearsighted comprehension of the issue
of this question." Cardinal Manning
says, "Catholic Church is either the
masterpiece of
Satan or the kingdom of the son of God."
Cardinal Newman says a sacraidal order
is historically the essence of the
church of Rome. If not divinely
appointed, it is doctrinally the essence
of antichrist. This is Rome itself
saying it in themselves and that is
actually because they're so boastful
this comes out of their mouth. Correct?
And both these statements the issue is
clear and it is the same. Rome herself
admits openly admits that she is not if
she's not the very kingdom of Christ she
is that of
antichrist. Rome declares she is one or
the other. She herself propounds and
urges the solemn alternative. You shrink
from it do you? I accept it. Conscience
constrains me. History compels me,
Martin. If we forget history, we end up
where we are today. We saw it in the
previous episode. Yeah. That Catholicism
is being lifted above everything and
humanity is mesmerized. Yeah. They don't
see it
anymore. So, let's continue our
typology.
The next decree was the decree of
Das because the work had been stalled.
It wasn't progressing like it should and
you know Martin that's exactly what
happened in the reformation. Mhm. It was
going for a there was a stalling and a
stalling and then new impetus had to
come and so the Lord raised up other
people other than Martin Luther and
Melton and Tindle and all of those and
he said you know come come wake up read
your Bibles and the Anabaptists and then
later the Baptist said what about adult
baptism and issues of the Sabbath and
issue of congregationalism. and all of
these things. And then Wesley saying,
"No, we must do more. The temple of God
is the body, too. It must be kept
healthy and the law of God and all of
these issues." And there was just chaos,
right? So, it required a second decree.
Mhm. Ezra chapter 6 verse one. Then Das
the king made a decree and search was
made in the house of the rolls. So what
did Cyrus said? Let's go and check it
out. Where the treasures were laid up in
Babylon. And verse seven says, "Let the
work of this house of God alone. Let the
governor of the Jews and the elders of
the Jews build this house of God in his
place." So stop the opposition, said
Dyrus. Build a house.
Stop the opposition, built a
house. Didn't this happen in the
reformation? Yeah. We are we are
following it typologically step by step.
You understand this is what what it
means that there's nothing new under the
sun. There's nothing new. And when
people say, "But you know, we are crazy
because we think this is important or
that is important and where do you come
with the Sabbath and this and that and
the other?" Just hang in there. Study
the typology. Let's see where it leads
us. This is the word of God. Of course,
this is nothing else. Well, it's
supported a little bit about an
explanation of how it's applied. Yes. By
Graten Guinness, but it's the word of
God, right?
So moreover, this is verse 8. This is
Das. He says, "Moreover, I make a
decree, what you shall do to the elders
of these Jews for the building of this
house of God, that of the king's good,
even the tribute beyond the river forth
with expenses be given unto these men,
that they be not hindered." In other
words, get some order into this. Again,
start building an orderly structure.
make sure that you know the distribution
of means is properly controlled. Isn't
it amazing for the church? Isn't it
amazing? Every time when they try to do
something, God brings them back to
organization just to get it done even
though it wasn't go look this is a
second time. Yes. Did the first time
work out with organization?
There always a problem. There's always a
problem. But it comes back to it. It
comes back to it. You must do this. So,
we're going to still talk about uh the
church. Do we need it or is it okay to
say, "Well, to with the church, we're
going to just run with the spirit."
Well, I see. And two typologies already
a problem. All right. Okay, Martin,
let's not jump the gun, right? But this
this is fascinating to me. So,
eventually the temple was restored. What
does that mean, Martin? It means Christ
was back in the center. Y
start with the altar. That is your
sacrifice. Not this idolatry and this
pomp and glamour and and all of this
nonsense. Start with the basics. And
what did the first celebration entail?
The Passover was celebrated again. He
showing to him. What does the Passover
stand for? Christ and him crucified.
Behold the lamb of God that taketh away
the sins of the world. So chapter 6
tells us, "And the children of the
captivity kept the Passover upon the
14th day of the first month. They
followed the rules.
For the priests and the Levites were
purified together, all of them were pure
and killed the Passover for all the
children of the captivity and for their
brethren, the priests, and for
themselves. And the children of Israel,
which were come again out of captivity,
and all such as had separated themselves
unto them from the filthiness of the
heathen of the land to seek the Lord God
of Israel did
eat. So who ate? All those that had
separated themselves. Martin, that's a
swear word these days. Mhm. You don't
separate. You
ecommen ecommenize if there's such a
word. You come into ecumenical
relations. You don't separate.
But God says
separate. It even says separate unto the
law. But we'll come to that. So what
happened here was Christ was once again
the center of the faith
also in the reformation. M the idolatry
was swept
away and Christ was back in the center.
Oh, that didn't go down well. No. So, in
the Oxford movement back, they brought
the idolatrous statues back. They
brought the altar back. They brought the
mass. And even Gratan Guine says, "Oh,
what
happened?" Right? What happened? How can
we how can we not see it? How is it even
possible? Now, did the reform stop
there? No. No. There was some more work
to be done,
right? Chapter 7. Now, after these
things in the reign of
Artus, king of Persia, and now we've
moved past the decree of Cyrus. We've
moved past the decree of Das. Now comes
the third
decree art cirus. Now his decree did not
pertain to the temple because the temple
was restored under the decrees of Cyrus
and Das. His decree was that Jerusalem
may be restored.
Rebuild the walls, houses to dwell in.
So what does that mean, Martin? What
what does that mean? It can't just be in
the Bible as a historic fact that there
was to be a reconstruction of a
destroyed building, right? So now they
got Christ in the center, but something
has something needs to be
added. So Ezra the son of Sariah, the
son of Azariah, the son of Hilkia, and
there's a long list. I'm not going to go
through it all. We jump to verse six.
This Ezra went up from Babylon and he
was a ready scribe in the law of Moses.
Let's get back to the Bible. The Bible
is central. The word of God is central.
Solar script.
What did the others say?
No. No. Tradition.
[Laughter]
Tradition. My grandfather did it like
this. I'm not changing. which the Lord
God of Israel had given and not a pope.
But that's also an amazing um statement.
Yeah. That the law of Moses was also
given by God to Moses. Correct. Not him.
He thought it up himself. And the king
granted him all his requests according
to the hand of the Lord his God upon
him. So who really granted him his
requests? God. God. Yeah. He used the
pagan king.
But it was God that did it. Now there's
a very interesting history around uh
this king and the whole story of Esther
and everything. So there was influence
and God was brilliant how he put it
together. We don't have time to go into
all of
that. So why did this happen? Well,
let's have a look. For Ezra had prepared
his heart to seek the law of the Lord
and to do it and to teach in Israel
statutes and judgments. Let's get back
to what God said and not back to what
tradition and humanity had said.
And this is the copy of the letter that
King Artexus gave unto Ezra the priest,
the scribe, even a scribe of the words
of the commandments of the Lord and his
statutes of Israel. Get back to the
word. Do what it says. Will there be
opposition? Oh, for sure. So, that is
the wall that you have to build again.
Ah, now we're getting to a wall stage,
right? We have to get to a wall.
Therefore, we need another decree which
comes from God. Restore the
wall. All right? So, Ezra gathered the
people of renown and set the priesthood
in order. And then he started initiating
reforms. The people were still
paganized. Yeah. Yeah. Everybody didn't
have all the garbage out of their head.
Everybody's doing their own thing.
So, the first thing he does, he prays
about intermarriage.
H now we have to put that which is a
type into an anti-ypological context.
Now when these things were done the
princes came to me saying the people of
Israel and the priests and the Levites
have not separated themselves from the
people of the lands doing according to
their abominations. Even the Canaanites,
the Hittites, the Perizzites, the
Jebusites, the Ammonites, the Moabites,
the Egyptians, and the Amorites.
Paganism is in their heads.
There's synretatism. They're not
thinking
straight. Why? Because they have taken
the daughters for themselves and for
their sons, so that the holy seed have
mingled themselves with the people of
those lands. Yay, the hand of the
princes and the rulers has been chief in
this
trespass. Men, they're practicing
syncratism. M so these women's of course
typogically stand for other churches
other religions other thinking patterns
and if you start mixing the two you're
going to have syncratism that's a
problem and then the most of the the
rulers preachers were doing this and
once you start compromising on this
level like Ratan Guinea says if you see
the candles if you see this run run.
It's syncratism. You're taking away the
emphasis from Christ. Separate yourself
from this
ideology. And said, "Oh my God, I'm
ashamed and blushed to lift my face to
thee, my God, for our iniquities are
increased over our head, and our
trespass is grown up under unto the
heavens. Since the days of our fathers
have we been in great
trespass, and unto this day, and for our
iniquities have we, our kings, our
priests, been delivered into the hand of
the kings of the lands, to the sword, to
captivity, to spoil, to confusion of
faith, as it is this day. Do we have
this problem with us? It's still alive
and kicking. And then verse 14, should
we again break thy commandments and join
in affinity with the people of these
abominations? Shall we sit in ecumenical
councils, Martin? No. Shall we pretend
that we are on the same
page? I don't mind speaking to people,
but can we go into an alliance with
people? They've used that little excuse
the whole time. And that's why we're
sitting in the mess that we have. All
right. W not thou be angry with us till
thou has consumed us so that there
should be no remnant nor escaping. But
this mindset is alive and well and
living this very day.
So now we jump from Ezra to Nehemiah
because Nehemiah is now appointed by the
king as governor
and he's come to have a look at the wall
of Jerusalem. It's horrendous. It's in
tatters. In other words, God's
requirements, his
laws, his protective barrier against
idolatry is
lying shattered. There is a breach in
the wall. It's full of holes. Remember
that Roman Catholicism changed the
commandments. They knocked so many holes
in the wall. It's like Babylon
destroying the wall. That's what they
done. So now enter Nehemiah. He's not a
prophet. He's not a priest. He's a
governor. He's going to come and sort it
out. And he was the king's cupbearer.
So he must have been very trustworthy
because you don't pour the king's cup
uh if you don't trust that person
because there could be poison in the
cup, right?
So Nehemiah and the words of Nehemiah
the son of Hakiah and it came to pass in
the months of Chisloo in the tw 20th
year as I was in Shushan the palace. So
he's up there with the king. He's the
cupbearer. Jump to verse three. And they
said unto me, this is now the people
reporting to him from what's happening
in
Jerusalem. And they say, "The remnant
that are left of the captivity there in
the province are in great affliction and
reproach. The wall of Jerusalem also is
broken down, and the gates thereof are
burnt with
fire." Now, the wall stands for the
protection.
There was a wall around the temple. It
stood for the righteousness of Christ.
Righteousness is right doing. I've come
to do thy will, oh my God. It stands for
the law. The gate stands for the portal
which is Christ who invites you into his
righteousness. Meaning coming back into
harmony with the law. Yeah. This is what
is typologically being portrayed here.
And like in that time, the remnant that
was left out of Babylon is an affliction
because it's it's in chaos. It's in
chaos. That the ten commandments had
been totally obliterated by a pagan
culture. And I said, I beseech thee, oh
Lord, God of heaven, the great and
terrible God that keepeth covenant and
mercy for them that love him and observe
his commandments. Can you see the
typology there? So Martin, are we insane
when we start speaking about we have to
keep the commandments? No. Not as a
means to salvation because by the law no
one will be saved, but because Christ
has saved you. You come back into
harmony with the law. Like all of these
show, first put Christ in the center
back and then because of that you build
the law. The Absolutely spot on. All
right. Isaiah
58:12 says that this was going to happen
sometime in the future. Because
remember, he was before the exile.
And he said, "And they that shall be of
thee shall build the old waste places.
Thou shalt raise up the foundations of
many generations, and thou shalt be
called the repairer of the
bridge, the restorer of paths to dwell
in. Any government has a law. God's
kingdom has a law. It had been
shattered. It needed to be restored.
It's amazing that some people want to
put Christ back in the center, but then
they don't want the law to come. They
don't want the wall. Yeah. We don't want
your government. We'll take care of
that. You just sit up there in heaven.
We'll rule down with our laws. Thank
you. You saved us, but we'll take it
from here. We'll take it from here.
Yeah. So Nehemiah goes and inspects the
the wall. Now the opposition is so
great. Mhm. That he does it by night.
Well, to go and check out Oh, Martin. He
does it by night. You know, there was a
time in history which was called the
dark
ages. It was so
dark. They went with their their little
torches and they looked at the wall and
they said, you know, Wesley says, you
know, shouldn't we keep the
commandments? Shouldn't we keep the
commandment? Col says, what about the
Sabbath? Is there a hole in this wall?
Oh, they were upset. Even their own
people. Oh, they were so upset. They
dragged them through the streets,
plucked their beards out, beat them up,
ran their cattle through their meetings.
So, poor
Jer Nehemiah does it by night. And uh
Nehemiah 2:9, "And then came to the
governor beyond the river and gave them
the king's letters. Now the king had
sent captains of the army and horsemen
with
me." Ah, is there a little bit of show
of strength here? Yeah.
Uh so God sends his angels with you and
says, "I want this sorted out." Exactly.
Now when son
Balot, there's always a
Sambalot the Horonite and Tobaya the
servant the Ammonite heard of it. It
grieved them exceedingly. And there was
come a man to seek the welfare of the
children of Israel. What's going on
here? a modern
Ammonite,
Horonite, you know, these people, they
were somehow affiliated to Abrahamic
religions,
but they were upset. Yeah. Now, in the
middle ages after Protestantism had
restored some of these things and
somebody came with a new idea, were the
Protestants upset? Oh, yes. Very much
so. And the Catholics were upset. Both
of them. you were in trouble either way.
They were
upset. So then I told them of the hand
of my God, which was good upon me, as
also the king's words that he had spoken
unto me, and they said, "Let us rise up
and build." So they strengthened their
hands for the good work. So he's
encouraging God's people. You know,
forget about the opposition. Let's go.
But when Sambalat the Horonite and
Tobaya the servant the Ammonite and
Gishm the Arabian. So they they're
getting a couple of people to help them
in their in their apostasy and and
gaining. Right. They laughed us to scorn
and despised us and said, "What is this
thing you do? Will you rebel against the
king?"
Interesting, right? Yeah. Yeah. Always
say who didn't Israelites. Didn't the
Jews also say that Jesus was rebelling
against Caesar? Yeah. Yeah. Who's Who do
you think you are? Who do you think you
are? What do you think you're
doing? Verse 20. Then answered them and
said unto them, "The God of heaven, he
will prosper us. Therefore, we his
servants will arise and build. But you
have no portion, nor right, nor memorial
in Jerusalem.
you with all your opposition. I'm going
to ignore you. I'm going to carry on.
I'm going to set my face like flint. Do
your worst.
So, here's a quote from the southern
watchman which reads, "Angels view the
church as Nehemiah viewed
Jerusalem. With sorrowstricken heart,
the visitor from afar gazed upon the
ruined defenses of his loved Jerusalem.
And is it not thus that angels of heaven
survey the condition of the church of
Christ? Like the dwellers of Jerusalem,
we become accustomed to the existing
evils and often are content with making
no effort to remedy them. But how are
these evils regarded by beings divinely
illuminated?
Do not they like Nehemiah look with
sorrow burdened heart upon the ruined
walls and gates burned with fire? Are
not everywhere visible the shameful
tokens of backsliding from God and
conformity with a sinloving and
truth-thhating world? In these days of
darkness and peril, who is able to stand
in defense of Zion and show her any
good? her spiritual state and prospects
are not in accordance with the light and
privileges bestowed of God. Is that a
true statement? Yes. And it's talking
about God's church. God's church. So now
it's time to repair the bridge. Yes.
Okay. Now remember, we've gone through
Ezra. Mhm. They rebuilt the temple. They
put Christ back in the center
antity reformation time.
Now they're going to have to restore the
government of God. The authority in your
life. Yes. No. But we're the authority.
He must be there. You listen to us. No.
No. We want to listen to God. No. No.
No. No. No. Some Tobaya. No. You will
not do
it. So chapter 4, it's a beautiful
chapter. I I really identify with
chapter 4.
And it came to pass that when some Balot
heard that we builded the wall, in other
words, restoring the commandments. Mhm.
We're now a little bit further in the
reformatory period. Yeah. Yeah. Now we
are about in the 1800s.
He was wroth.
And he took great
indignation and mocked the Jews.
Well, mocked those that want to restore
the commandments of God. Right. Started
with Wesley. They mocked him to scorn.
Then it went to the Adventists. Mhm. And
they were mocked to scorn. Yep. Because
they included then also the Sabbath,
right? But we'll come to that. And he
spoke before his brethren and the army
of Samaria. Woo. who's becoming
militarized and said, "What are these
feeble Jews? Will they fortify
themselves? Will they sacrifice? Will
they make an end in a day? Will they
revive the stones out of the heaps of
rubbish which are burnt?" Now, Tobaya
the Ammonite was by him. There's an
alliance here. And he said, "Even that
which they build, if a fox go up, he
shall even break down their stone wall."
Martin, this is almost like Catholicism
and
Protestantism aligning themselves
against those that want to repair the
breach.
And that's a not a possibility. That is
how it shall be. And remember, Sam Balot
was from Samaria. Mhm. And Samaria was
syncratism. Yeah. And that's
Catholicism.
All right. Now, Tobaya the Ammonite was
by him. They're together.
Here, oh our God, for we are despised
and turn their reproach upon their own
head and give them for a prey in the
land of
captivity. So this is the prayer of
Nehemiah. The should be the prayer of
God's people. So how are they building?
Well, they have a sword in one hand and
a troll in the other hand. Therefore set
I in the lower places behind the wall
and on the higher places. I even set the
people after their families with their
swords, their spears, and their bows.
And I looked and rose up and said unto
the nobles, and to the rulers, and to
the rest of the people, "Be not afraid
of them. Remember the Lord, which is
great and terrible, and fight for your
brethren, your sons, your daughters,
your wives, and your houses." Are we now
in a war? Yes. They which build it on
the wall, and they that bear burdens,
with those that laid it, everyone with
one of his hands wrought in the work,
and with the other hand held a weapon.
Here's a good weapon. Let's pick it up.
Yeah. Yeah. Let's pick it up. So now
you're busy fighting for the Lord. Yes.
But you're building his wall strong.
You're building the wall and you don't
stop building the wall. There's a breach
in the wall and you're going to get
opposition from Catholicism and from
Protestantism. Sambalat and Tobaya are
going to be aligned against you even
inside of the wall. You're going to get
that. You're going to get it. We'll
we'll get to that. We'll get ah theology
is beautiful. I love
it. All right. So, Satan still uses
contempt and derision.
This comes from Bible commentary and it
says the experience of Nehemiah is
repeated in the history of God's people
in this time. Oh, that's that's just a
confirmation of what we're reading.
Those who labor in the cause of truth
will find that they cannot do this
without exciting the anger of its
enemies both within and without because
some are building with wood and hay and
stubble. Exactly.
Though they have been called of God to
the work in which they are engaged and
their course is approved of him, they
cannot escape reproach and derision.
They will be denounced as visionary,
unreliable, scheming, hypocritical,
anything in short that will suit the
purpose of their enemies. The most
sacred things will be represented in a
ridiculous light to amuse the ungodly.
A very small amount of sarcasm and low
wit united with envy, jealousy,
impiiety, and hatred is sufficient to
excite the mirth of the profane scoffer.
And these presumptuous gestures sharpen
one another's ingenuity and embolden
each other in their blasphemous work.
Contempt and derision are indeed painful
to human nature, but they must be
endured by all who are true to God. It
is the policy of Satan, thus to turn
souls from doing the work which the Lord
has laid upon
them. I'm getting a fair amount of hate
mail lately. Martin,
I just I was just thinking on that exact
portion. Walter fight saint or snack.
Well, interesting stuff like that. It's
interesting stuff. And then the problem
is when I read this, I see those
accusers. Yes. They're everywhere. Yeah.
And I see the the spirit that's being
led there because they believe like
those people that want to build this
kingdom on earth. Yes. That they are
righteous and they are the right ones
and they're going to be the only ones
standing. So, let's continue this saga
because this is getting fascinating. And
likewise at the same time said I unto
the people, "Let everyone with his
servant lodge within
Jerusalem, that in the night they may be
a god to us and labor on in the day." We
need to be in Jerusalem. Now, what does
Jerusalem stand for? Doesn't it stand
for God's people? Yes.
What? You have to stay in the church?
Oh, is everybody perfect in that church?
I can't see through this typology any
time where they said, "Okay, leave
Jerusalem. Let's get out of here." No.
Because Jerusalem is just full of
apostasy and the wall and all these
people here. We I'm fed up with this.
I'm fed up with I'm going to stand
outside Jerusalem.
So neither I nor my brethren nor my
servants nor the men of the god which
followed me none of us put off our
clothes saving that everyone put them
off for washing. Oh, that's beautifully
put. What is the typology? Ah, 1 Peter
1:13. Wherefore g up the loins of your
mind, be sober and hope to the end for
the grace that is to be brought unto you
at the revelation of Jesus Christ. So
this typology has a deeper meaning.
And Luke
12:35, let your loins be girded about
and your lights burning. Yeah. Keep your
robes of righteousness on. That's the
righteousness of Christ. And if you want
to wash it, you wash it in the blood.
Correct. Now, conspiracy against
Nehemiah. Martin conspiracies. There's
no such thing as a conspiracy, is there?
No. We are the the conspiracy theorists.
Nehemiah 6 vers1. Now it came to pass
when
Sambalot and Tobaya and Gishop the
Arabium and the rest of our enemies
Martin, it's becoming universal now.
You're going to have a tough time,
right? Heard that I had builded the wall
and that there was no breach left
therein. Mhm. Though at the time I had
not set up the doors upon the gates,
that some Balot and Gishm sent unto me,
saying, "Come, let us meet together in
some one of the villages on the plain of
Ona, but they thought to do me
mischief." And I sent messages unto
them, saying, I'm doing a great work so
that I cannot come down. Why should the
work cease while I leave it and come
down to you? Martin, don't go and listen
to these people. No. Uh you can try
sometimes to take to bring them up to
you where you're building the wall, but
they sometimes they all most of the time
they just say no thank you. No thank
you. I'll stay here outside of the wall
and build our own little I'm going to
build my own little empire and I'm going
to swat you like a fly with a fly
swatter when you come down. Yeah. and
sit at my table because you must
remember they've got the
pure robes on themselves. Now it gets
interesting, right? Nehemiah 6:17.
Moreover, in those days, the nobles of
Judah, oh no,
sent many
letters unto Tobaya. Of course, it's
your own people now. And the letters of
Tobaya came back unto them. They were
modern. The letters in the ecumenical
council were going backwards and
forward. I've seen some of those. We're
sorry that Nehemiah is irritating you.
We're sorry. He he you know what he said
to to the Roman Catholic pre plet and
his name was Sambala. He said, "I'm not
coming down to you." How could he not
listen to this important personality
after all? you
know my turn and the nobles now must I
leave the church because the nobles sent
many letters to Tobaya
it's it's illogical all right it's
giving up actually so actually I wrote
down there really is it possible that
the nobles of Judah Martin we have to
leave immediately
huh because of the nobles no I'm sorry
I'm sticking I'm sticking. The nobles
can leave. I'm not coming down. We're
building this wall. We're building this
wall. So whether you write letters or
not, enjoy yourself. I've seen some of
those letters. And even if somebody
outside there makes videos and call this
fellow, we have this fellow is preaching
this nonsense about uh medieval history
and the papacy being antichrist. Shall
we shut him down? And the letters go
backwards and forwards. I've seen those
letters. They're very interesting. So
Martin, you get a union through a
draconic bond. So here's another
interesting quote. A spirit of hatred
and opposition to the hub Hebrews formed
the bond of union. Uhhuh. And created
the mutual sympathy amongst different
bodies of men who otherwise might have
wared against each other.
I love this. It It's a reoccurring
thing. This Yes. From that day, Pilate
and Herod were friends where before they
were at enmity with each other. This
will illustrate what we frequently
witness in our day in the existing union
of men of different
denominations to oppose the present
truth whose only bond seems to be that
which is draconic in its nature,
manifesting hatred and bitterness
against the remnant who keep the
commandments of God. Nevertheless, we
made our prayer unto our God and set a
watch against them day and night because
of them, said
Nehemiah. Is the typology absolutely
crystal clear? Definitely. So the next
point is that Ezra reads the law.
So what does he do, Martin? Chapter 8
verse one. And all the people gathered
themselves together as one man unto the
street that was before the Watergate.
And they spoke unto Ezra the scribe, to
bring the book of the law of Moses,
which the law had commanded to Israel,
and Ezra the priest, brought bel the law
before the congregation, both of men and
women, and all that could hear with
understanding upon the first day of the
seventh month. So they put down a
podium. He climbed up a couple of steps
so that everybody could see him. And he
said, "Listen folks." Yeah. Listen
folks. This is what the word says. And
if you have half a brain, then listen to
what the word says. And those that had
understanding listened. And some Tobaya
screamed their head off, right? Because
they couldn't gain say the word. No.
There's no way that you can do it. I'm
the Lord. I change not. Do not think
that I've come to abolish the law. Not
one jot or one tit will buy. Oh, but
that doesn't include the Sabbath, for
example. Right. Of course, that's
something different. All right. So verse
8 says, so they read in the book of the
law of God
distinctly. It says so
here gave the sense that makes sense.
It's logical and caused them to
understand the reading. And in spite of
it, many said, "No, no, doesn't fit my
paradigm." No, my little ministry that
I'm running is the perfect one. You can
stay in your apostate one. Yes. You stay
there with your letters to
Tobaya. So what did they do, Martin?
They celebrated the feast of
boos. So where are we now in history?
This must be just before we're going
home because this represents homegoing.
This is before the coming of Christ.
Yes. So what happens now? And on the
second day were gathered together the
chief of the fathers of the people, the
priests, the Levites, and Ezra the
scribe, even to understand the words of
the law. And they found written in the
law which the Lord had commanded by
Moses that the children of Israel should
dwell in booths in the feast of the
seventh
month
representing their coming out of Egypt
being freed and also representing coming
out of this world and going to Christ.
And the seed of Israel separated
themselves from all strangers.
That's going to be tough for for anybody
in this day and age. Yeah. And stood and
confessed their sins and iniquities of
their fathers. And they stood up in
their places, read the book of the law
of the Lord their God. One fourth part
of the day and another fourth part they
confessed and worshiped the Lord their
God. And because of all this, we make a
sure
covenant and write it and our princes,
Levites, and priests seal unto it. So
Martin, there will be princes and there
will be Levites and there will be
priests that will make a covenant for
sure. They will want to stand with this
whole rebuilding and putting everything
where it's supposed to be and others
will write letters to Tobaya. Toiah. So
what? That's their problem, right? You
can do it. Go and write your letters.
Chapter
12. And at the dedication of the wall of
Jerusalem, they sought the Levites out
of all their places to bring them to
Jerusalem to keep the dedication with
gladness, both with thanksgiving, with
singing, with symbols, with sulties, and
with harps. Isn't this what happened
when they discovered the centrality of
Christ? Exactly. And it it cannot be any
other way. If you really find Christ
where he's in the center, Yes. Then you
will let go of all these other things.
And then when you discover the
principles of his government and want to
come into harmony with it, won't you
also have singing and sultries and
harps? It comes
naturally. Aha. So what will be the
final reform according to this typology?
We've going through it step by step and
nobody can say it's not the word of God.
No. But you can like that portion said
it's making sense. All right. So we come
to the last chapter Nehemiah 13.
And on that day they read the book of
Moses and the audience of the people and
therein was found written that the
Ammonite and the Moabitete should not
come into the congregation of God
forever.
Unless of course he converts. Yes. Like
Ruth was a moabitete test. He does not
come in as an Ammonite. It We don't want
an Ammonite in here. We don't want a
Moabitete. You leave your gods outside.
You come and do your God will be my God
and your people will be my people. Then
you're welcome. Yeah. But otherwise with
your Ammonite and Moabitete ideas, you
stay there. We don't want you. We're not
ecumenical. Yeah. We're not going to
compromise. No.
And before this, Eliaship the priest
having the oversight of the chamber of
the house of our God was allied to
Tobaya. But he was an ammonite.
I don't know what's going on here. So
the priest
was allied to
Tobaya and he had prepared for him a
great
chamber where four times they laid the
meat offerings, the frankincense and the
vessels and the tithes and the corn and
the wine and the oil which was commanded
to be given to the Levites and the
singers and the porters and the
offerings of the priest. They put him
into the economic hub. Oh, and I see
that it was done there where the tithes
are and the offerings and everything.
So, we must leave this place.
So, there he is, the Ammonite with his
Ammonite ideas running the finances of
the church. Yeah, Martin, this couldn't
possibly happen, could it? And if we
have to get out of here. No, no, no.
Let's read on. Nehemiah 13:7. And I came
to Jerusalem because he'd gone back and
now he was coming back for his second
term and understood of the evil that
Eliah did for Tobaya in preparing him a
chamber in the courts of the house of
God. How dare
they? And it grieved me saw Martin.
Yeah, let it grieve you. It has to.
Therefore, I cast forth all the
household stuff of Tobaya out of the
chamber. Sooner or later, Martin, it's
going to get thrown out. It will get
out. Does it say that we all left
because Tobaya was there and because
Ilia ship was in cahoots with him?
Doesn't say so. They chucked him out,
right? No. Is there a typology in that?
It will get there definitely.
This is fascinating. And then the final
reform in those days saw I and Judas
some treading wine presses on the
Sabbath, bringing in sheav, lading
asses, also wine grapes, figs, and all
manner of burdens which they brought
into Jerusalem on the Sabbath
day. And I testified against them in the
day wherein they sold
vittles. There dwelt men of Tire.
That's a symbol of the world economy,
right? also therein in Jerusalem. Yeah.
Unfortunately, which brought fish and
all manner of wear and sold on the
Sabbath unto the children of Judah in
Jerusalem. And then I contended with the
nobles of Judah. Who's he contending
with? The nobles? And I said unto them,
"What evil thing is this that you do and
profane the Sabbath day? Did not your
fathers thus? And did not our God bring
all this evil upon us and upon this
city? Yet ye bring more wroth upon
Israel by profaining the
Sabbath? And he cleared them out, right?
And then he put a holy area around
Jerusalem and said, "If you cross that
barrier, I'm going to zap you." M and
then one day the Bible says that the
armies of Rome will stand in that holy
place in that barrier. In other words,
they will put their standard their false
Sabbath in the place of the real
Sabbath. But this absolutely identifies
the final reform. Yeah. of the post
exile period with its type and its
antitype. So the work of reform carried
on by
Zerubbabel, Ezra and Nehemiah presents a
picture of a work of spiritual
restoration in the closing days of this
earth's history. Through the remnant of
Israel, God purposed to preserve in the
earth a knowledge of himself. They were
the guardians of the true worship, the
keepers of the holy oracles.
Irrespective of Tobias, irrespective of
cahoots, irrespective of leaders writing
letters, irrespective of giving the
economy over to some of
these people, irrespective of all those
things, if they had the law, they were
the guardians of the oracles.
They were the guardians of the true
worship, the keepers of the holy
oracles. Strong was the opposition they
had to meet. Heavy the burdens borne by
the leaders. But these men moved forward
in firm reliance on God, believing that
he would cause his truth to triumph. The
spiritual restoration of which the work
in Nehemiah's day was a symbol is
outlined in the words of Isaiah. Your
ancient ruins shall be rebuilt. You
shall raise up the foundations of many
generations. You shall be called the
repairers of the breach and restorers of
streets to dwell in. Isaiah
58:12. A breach has been made in God's
law. The wall that he placed around his
chosen ones for his their protection and
obedience to whose precepts of justice,
truth, and purity is to be their
perpetual safeguard. The prophet points
out the specific work of this remnant
people who build the wall. If you turn
back your foot from the Sabbath, from
doing your pleasure on my holy day, and
call the Sabbath a delight in the holy
of the Lord honorable. If you honor it,
not going your own way or seeking your
own pleasure or talking idly, then you
shall take delight in the Lord, and I
will make you ride on the heights of the
earth. Martin, is this the final work?
Yeah. Yes. We are right there. Typology
says so. Mhm. And the Bible, everything.
This is it. In time of the end, every
divine institution is to be restored.
The breach made in the law at the time
the Sabbath was changed by the man by
man is to be repaired. God's remnant
people are to show that the law of God
is the foundation of all enduring
reform. in clear distinct lines. They
are to present the necessity of
obedience to all the precepts of the
decalogue. Constrained by the love of
Christ, they are to cooperate with him
in building up the waste places. They
are to be repairers of the breach,
restorers of paths to dwell
in. So Martin, this is straight out of
Isaiah
58. and they shall be of thee shall
build the old waste places. This is what
he says. If you turn your foot from the
Sabbath, verse 13, from doing thy
pleasure on my holy day. But this is not
conjecture. This is biblical. And when
you busy with this, building the wall,
getting the law back into the place,
there will be people that are like Yeah.
atabaya and and Sambala and all of
those. Now, isn't it interesting that
the three synoptic gospels, Matthew,
Mark, and Luke, all of them have the
statement, for the son of man is Lord
even of the
Sabbath. Therefore, the Son of Man is
Lord also of the Sabbath. And he said
unto them, the Son of Man is Lord also
of the Sabbath. You cannot get away from
this final reform. It will be the final
issue. It's the final issue in this
whole typology of the post exile
restoration. Every time it will be the
final issue at the end of time as well.
We're going to be confronted with Salat
and
Tobias and the remnant. And we will have
nobles that are writing letters.
Absolutely. And some of them will put
the buyer in in a chamber in in a
chamber and give him whatever he
requires. You know what? He's going to
get chucked out. Exactly. Just God will
do the chucking. Absolutely. So Martin,
if the typology says so, history has
confirmed it so far. The final events
will revolve around the issues that we
have been talking about. It's biblical.
It is based on scripture. It's in the
law of God. Everything is in place. So
we can proclaim it without fear
irrespective of S. Balot or Tobaya.
Let's
pray. Heavenly
Father, thank you for giving us such a
clear picture of the reforms that need
to take place before you come and claim
the kingdom.
because you will claim not only a
kingdom but you will com you will also
claim
allegiance of your people to the
principles of that kingdom. And all
those who separate themselves unto the
law of God shall be part of that as long
as they acknowledge the lamb and him
slain appropriating his righteousness
and not a righteousness that comes from
their own unstable works. Bless
everybody in their decision is my prayer
in Jesus' name. Amen. Amen.
Heat. Heat.
[Music]